[Music]
so you found yourself a super-duper
hidden secret dungeon now did you well
good on you
time to go dungeon crawling oh but wait
yeah we're not talking about dungeon
exploration today but rather something
equally important preparation most of
the common complaints about breath the
wild I can totally get behind or at the
very least understand it from their
perspective I can see why people were
put off by the weapon durability system
I agree that the story could have been
more fleshed out and that the shrines
got repetitive after one hundred and
twenty iterations and I'm all in favor
of breath wah to not taking place during
monsoon season there's one complaint I
do have a particular gripe with though
it's not the most prominent of
criticisms but it's definitely out there
here's a very basic reenactment of that
complaint so I was in this shrine right
and I ran out of arrows which I needed
to progress so I had to leave the shrine
and go all the way to the shop to buy
some more I wanted to skip time and wait
for the rain to stop but I didn't have
any firewood or flint on me which was so
frustrating well guess what that's on
you buddy
breath of the wild is a game about
survival managing your resources and
equipment well you just want everything
handed to you on a silver platter I am
of course over exaggerating but I do
stand by the fact that preparing for a
challenge is half the fun it makes that
challenge all the more satisfying to
complete as opposed to the older
installments in the series there's no
limit to the amount of ammunition you
can carry so in that regard there's no
excuse not to make sure to have a decent
stock of arrows on you at all time the
same goes for other items that might
come in handy at any point me I always
make sure to have a torch and a coral
leaf on me it doesn't matter how good of
a weapon I may find I will just drop a
weaker one I try to make sure I have at
least a few different elemental weapons
on me just in case I run into an enemy
who's weak to that element especially
fire based weapons come in handy in case
I need to start an easy campfire light a
torch or burn an obstacle sure it sucks
having to sacrifice a valuable weapons
law just in case you need that one
specific thing to progress and Nintendo
might be wise to give these types of
items there
separate category instead of pooling
them all together with the other weapons
nonetheless it was a sacrifice I was
willing to make during my first
playthrough of the game call me old
school but I really feel like modern
video games have spoiled us a little too
much at times just a sheer thought that
a player might be annoyed or frustrated
to have to turn back and resupply has
driven developers to make sure they hand
us all the stuff we need right on the
spot at least in terms of the Zelda
series this approach has one unfortunate
side-effect namely giving away the
solution prematurely and sacrificing
responsible resource management for
convenience the early entries in the 3d
installments are particularly guilty of
this where the game designers purposely
place a specific item or ammunition in a
room just so we don't have to leave the
dungeon to restock what this essentially
does is hint that the solution before we
even have to think about it oh look it's
an endlessly respawning bush containing
Deku seeds
I guess there's probably a nice witch or
something I got a hit ah Deku Baba guess
I'm gonna need that stick tool at me
some fire in this room gee they are sure
handing out a lot of magic right before
I enter this door I'm guessing the boss
will probably be weak to magic attacks
now I cannot completely fault the older
games for doing this since as mentioned
before ammunition was capped at a
relatively low number so it was much
easier to run out of resources but it's
definitely not something I would like to
see repeated in the future with the
sequel to breath of the wild we will no
longer be restricted to the old system
which only let you carry so much stuff
at a time instead of placing jars around
with the necessary stuff inside I'm in
favor of giving that responsibility back
to the player if you didn't prepare a
decent amount of meals or potions in
advance with different status effects
and refills before you venture into a
dungeon you have no one to blame but
yourself the early 2d games who are a
lot more ruthless in that regard
ruthless but not completely unfair you
still found stuff you might need later
on in the dungeon but not necessarily in
the same room or right before a boss
fight in a Link to the Past it was
pretty much mandatory to carry at least
one or two bottles of magic potions with
you if you wanted to stand a chance at
clearing Turtle Rock or the ice palace I
do understand that Nintendo one Zelda to
be accessible for players of different
skill levels and breath of the wild -
definitely shouldn't be notoriously hard
Akins
Ultima Underworld when it comes to
dungeon crawling but a good challenge
shouldn't be avoided either I've
compiled a small list of things I think
would make for a nice inclusion in the
sequel when it comes to dungeon
preparation both in terms of items but
also gameplay mechanics keep in mind
these are just things I would like to
see they are not predictions when it
came to lighting your way in the dark
place the torches did the trick
however as mentioned before the big turn
noun was the fact that it hawks your
weapon slots I think a lantern similar
to the one from Twilight Princess would
make a welcome return this item would
consume lantern oil just like in the
afro mentioned game but it wouldn't take
up space in your inventory the lantern
oil itself could function the same way
as any of the other collectibles we find
in the game something we can either mine
or buy and hey link uses cooking oil
when he's preparing food so why not make
it a collectible right the second
disadvantage the torches had was the
inability to use a weapon climb or do
anything else really while you're
holding it but this problem was already
solved in Twilight Princess and in
breadth of the wild we can see NPCs
walking around with lanterns attached to
their hips or their backpacks this way
links hands would still be free to
perform other actions while still having
a source of light we also find lanterns
laying around stables and houses so we
don't need torches anymore we have the
technology in the e3 trailer from last
year we can see that link and Zelda are
very well prepared for their journey
into Hyrule's underground with a packing
animal outfitted to the brim with all
kinds of bags and material strapped to
its body so here's a crazy idea instead
of planting some spare weapons on your
wall what if we could store extra items
on our trusty steed once you register a
horse in your original it got outfitted
with a saddle this was pure aesthetics
though and it didn't have any other
function it would be an interesting
addition if we could outfit it with
extra saddlebags that can hold a limited
amount of spare items basically
functioning as a secondary inventory we
might not always be able to venture deep
into a dungeon with it but we could at
least leave him or her at the entrance
or in the central room as a backup
storage when you run out of a specific
item or ammunition we can transfer stuff
from our saddlebag into our inventory in
order to keep it reasonable and somewhat
close to reality this inventory should
of course
not be too big let's say for instance a
maximum of two weapon slots one or two
bows and shields and a couple of
materials and collectibles we don't want
to make our poor ride collapse from
exhaustion now do we the many shops and
merchants around Hyrule sold us arrows
apparel food and other materials but no
weapons bows or shields which was a bit
strange if you think about it how did
all these other adventurers obtain their
gear now as I mentioned in my breath of
the wild milestone video the weapon
durability system didn't really bother
me that much but if we're going to have
large and complex dungeons or caves to
explore in the sequel this will become a
problem finding an entrance to a dungeon
only to realize half of your inventory
is either empty or damaged is not
exactly ideal since we would have to
spend quite some time randomly scouring
a landscape just to look for some decent
weapons it would be best if we have the
option to buy or repair them just in
case the Master Sword decides to bug out
on us again shops could be limited to
only selling low to mid-level gear
enough to keep us going but without
taking away the exploration part of
discovering rare and powerful weaponry
in the overworld or high-level weapons
could simply come at a very hefty price
alternatively we could be able to repair
certain weapons by sacrificing materials
instead of just gemstones we could for
instance be able to mine precious metals
gold silver copper etc the stronger the
weapon the more rare and expensive the
materials you would have to sacrifice
for a quick fix
Guardian based weapons would be repaired
with ancient parts wooden weapons with
wooden fiber you get the point
this way we can still have weapon
durability to a certain degree but also
options to restock on weapons more
easily for means of preparing for a
serious dungeon crawl being able to
craft certain items on the spot given
you have the right materials would be an
amazing addition to the game in my
opinion this doesn't have to be as
complex as in other games of course with
tons and tons of options skill levels
and combinations this isn't an RPG but I
don't see why link shouldn't be able to
craft some basic necessities suppose the
devs decide to skip my lantern idea and
simply stick to the torches if say I
have a bundle of wood and some other
myth
like cloth or a specific monster part I
should be able to craft something as
simple as a torch right or create some
extra arrows from sticks and a piece of
metal or a very basic emergency bow from
a stick and some string again they don't
have to go too crazy with this and make
it as complex and varied as the cooking
system the weapons and ammo shouldn't be
as robust and high-quality as their
quote unquote
real stuff but some easy craftable z'
that don't break the game's difficulty
but rather make your life a little bit
easier in emergency situations would go
a long way keep in mind that when I make
a video like this it's not my intention
to set you up for disappointment the
final product could include none of the
stuff that I'm talking about and still
be a great game it's meant to be fun and
harmless theory crafting and I love
reading through my comments to see what
you guys come up with we will just have
to wait and see what Nintendo comes up
with once they finally reveal more and
hope that some of our wishes may have
been heard before I end the video I want
to quickly give you an update about the
channel yeah you know this was coming
eventually I held off from even
considering to create a patreon since my
channel is still relatively young and I
first wanted to prove my worth to you
all and show you what I have to offer if
you're a fan of the channel and you
would like to contribute financially its
greatly appreciated however if you enjoy
the channel and you don't have the means
or simply don't want to spend your
hard-earned money that is completely
fine as fans you are all equal in my
eyes and I'm not going to treat anyone
differently or only respond to people
who contribute now of course I will have
reward tears for those who choose to
donate since it's only fair but nothing
changes if you're only here to watch
it's just as valuable to me after all
what would my content be without an
audience the reason why patreon benefits
me is because it allows me to free up my
time from my corporate job to focus more
on the channel eventually I want to try
to switch to two videos per week and
only relying on YouTube revenue is
simply not a strategic choice since I'm
only one guy and my content isn't
exactly the type you can hammer out in
one day revenue also tends to fluctuate
so it's not something you should put all
your cards on I'm not looking to become
a rich celebrity youtuber guy or
anything that's just
for me but as long as I can pay my bills
go on a hike now and again and continue
to make cool videos for you all I'm a
happy camper
if you decide to donate I don't know
what else to say but thank you and of
course thank you all for watching this
video and sitting through this little
ramble at the end next week you'll be in
for a real treat since I will be
collaborating with my friend and fellow
youtuber who is none other than the one
and only masked Nintendo bandit I hope
you look forward to seeing what we have
in store for you as always if you
haven't already consider leaving a like
subscribing to the channel and become
lost in the maze with me until the next
video this is dawn signing off and have
a good one